we've just received this word backstage
mr. mrs. Bartley Emerson of Silver
Spring Maryland just returned from their
neighborhood theater they drove the
babysitter home and then turned on their
television set they want to know why
they're not seeing Richard Dixon the
ghost ship mr. mrs. Emerson and anyone
else who has just joined us tonight the
motion picture industry is bringing you
our annual Academy Awards program and to
present the awards for art direction we
have called upon two distinguished
citizens of our community whose
performances invariably raised motion
picture acting into the realm of art
miss Eva Marie Saint mr. Gregory Peck
the art director makes a movie look the
way it does he designs the sets and
adapts location sides to complement the
action the atmosphere and the mood of
the story to fit that big wide screen
bringing to your theaters such widely
diversified backgrounds as Paris and San
Francisco Japan and Kentucky the
following were nominated for best
achievement in art direction and set
decoration the nominations are funny
face art direction by hal pereira and
george w davis set direction by sam
comer and ray Moore lay girls art
direction by William a Horning and Jean
Allen and that direction by Edward Lee
Willis and Richard petrol Al joy art
direction by Walter holster set
decoration by William Coonan and Louis D
eyes Raintree County art direction by
William a Horning and early McCleary set
direction by Edwin B Willis and Hugh
hunt sayonara art direction by Ted
Howard set decoration by Robert
Priestley the winner please sayonara
I'd like to thank the motion picture
industry for this wonderful moment in my
life